поговоримо з вами про цифри та обговоримо три
питання
три питання з мемов до чого тут
порошенка до чого тут
зелінський і найважливіше питання що з
цим усім робити
чемпіонську п'ятірку державних
президентських компаній які отримали
збитки
відкриває енергоатом у 2019 році його
прибуток був 3,8 мільярдів у 2020
збитки склали 4 та 8 сумарно мінус
вийшов 8,6 мільярдів тобто прибутку
зжерли пішли у збитку і того мінус 8
цілих шість десятих мільярдів можливо
тільки той, хто пов'язаний з ринком зерна
знає про існування державні
продовольство жорнової корпорації я
чесно кажучи, ніколи не займався
продовольством і не знав про неї
існуванні взагалі та збитків ця
корпорація завдала 2020 року в наших
вами грошей зжерла майже 6 мільярдів
так все звучить 5,8 мільярдів насправді
справі це 5 мільярдів у 800 мільйонів
наших з вами грошей
чистий збиток ось така рука передає
привіт сережці драбинка ось таке тому
що укрзалізниця
те саме слово, яке не можуть
вимовити наші брати за поребрика
укрзалізниці
спробуй повтори 2019 рік прибуток 3
мільярда 2020 року збитки майже 12
додаткове бонусне питання при чому
тут всерйоз ященко
а при тому, що насправді
збитки за два роки склали майже
п'ятнадцять мільярдів
почесне третє місце сировини вже тобі
велике привезе друге почесне місце з
захопленими криками [ __ ] собі
займаючись укренерго 2019 року отримала
прибуток та 1 мільярд
майже два мільярди прибутку від 1 цілих
вісімдесят шість сотих
у 2020 збитків двадцять сім із половиною
мільярдів
сумарно збиток загальної та тобто вкрали
прибуток плюс ще якщо збитків тобто
сумарно вкрадено 29 мільярдів 360
мільйонів 29 мільярдів вкрали 29
мільярдів
німеру собі правда гірше не буде
говорили вони гірше не буде
буде говорили на два роки тому
говорили і було не буде це ж
однозначно було зрозуміло і буде гірше
стандартна чудова футболка для
сьогоднішнього відео мало бути я ж
вас попереджав я ж вам казав у мене
така є і так тут має бути фанфари
така музика то будинок феєрверки салюти
ось ці ось таке переможець
переможець на першому місці у нас
переможець нак нафтогаз україни повинен
бути дві руки таких наскільки тут має
бути рук тому що в 2019 році прибуток
нак нафтогазу становила майже десять
мільярдів прибуток 10 мільярдів у 2020
збитків майже 37
тобто зжерли прибутку на 10 мільярдів
завдали збитків 37 сумарно це майже
сорок сім мільярдів ваших грошей не
мільйонів ще раз тут не мільйонів
мільярдів та знаки оклику
мільярдів
[ __ ] весь прибуток у 10 мільярдів
є завдали збитків у 37 сумарно це 47
мільярдів
переможець гірше не буде гірше не буде
буде говорили ми ось вона вам гірша
47 мільярдів ваших грошей і кудись до
хлопчикам
виходячи з озвучених цифр
очевидні відповіді до чого тут порошенка
причому тут зелінський але відповідь на самий
важливе питання що з цим робити
ви повинні дати самостійно напишіть у
коментарі що ви думаєте що з цим
робити